mais pour le moment on était sur les
rumeurs parce que nabila est en colère
parce que yen allez vous avez qu'elle
est enceinte on l'a dit la semaine
dernière mais une rumeur comme quoi elle
portera un fauve en fait parce
qu'eux-mêmes et leurs effets à la rue
recours pardon à la gpa pour être
enceinte alors du coup pas pour avoir un
enfant pardon donc regarder ce qu'elle a
mis sur ces réseaux sociaux est belle la
photo est très jolie voilà je ne réussis
pas à ma vie tellement change-t-il tt
tête tu as pas trop top ce domaine
aventure bon voila et donc elle a poussé
un coup de gueule c'est pas sur laon là
le coup de gueule de l'abbé la voile à
regarder est ce que je lisais les comme
sous ma dernière photo star parce que
j'ai fait un shooting
avec mon ventre ce que je trouve ça trop
beau et je voyais des gens il dit c'est
un faux ventre et tout mais vous êtes
fous les gars moi j'aime trop porter mes
enfants c'est la base après les
personnes qui font ça je respecte si les
personnes veulent des enfants qui
peuvent pas les porter par rapport à des
preuves de santé ben voila mais prenant
mais c'est n'importe quoi parfois c'est
marrant est resté que ce qu ils
respectent
et respectent ce qui porte des faux
aimerait ce que tu adores
[Rires]
à voir
ce qui est marrant quand même et qui est
plutôt gratifiant pour l une des
dernières stars à avoir été accusé
d'avoir eu un faux ventre c'était
beyoncé à l'époque des cibles ou bien
sûr on avait même fait des captures est
touché au printemps montrant que c'est
un concept qui se plier et donc pour
répondre aux rumeurs elle a carrément
posé en bikini
elle montre son baby bump hier
d'ailleurs depuis hier sur twitter
nabila visiblement c'est pas du tout
info banques sont maintenant séparés
envoya elle bat la thalassa sur la plage
toute la journée en ce moment et en
thaïlande je crois on voit très bien que
ça à l'entraînement sont
bien à la presse hassan 2 jours beaucoup
du groupe bic et les bills à
moi je partage quelque chose avec nabila
sais c'est que j'ai le même en buteur en
c1 tu fais ton ton nom je suis enceinte
nord je vais le même coiffeur que nabila
céderait tu m'a confirmé et qu'elle
était bien enceinte et qu'il avait vu
son ventre et que voilà il n'y a pas de
débat elle est bel et bien mais voilà
bravo prochain bravo c'est une belle
vie
là foot et alors j'ai pas le même
coiffeur qu'un habile annonce avoir go
mais j'aimerais préciser que les rumeurs
ça peut faire ou défaire une star c'est
vraiment un truc assez surtout dans la
presse people c'est forcément on s'en
délecte beaucoup je prends l'exemple de
celle a forcément
michael jackson a contrario voilà il
dormait dans un caisson à oxygène fin
tous ces trucs là on fait aussi sa
légende et puis même en politique
hillary clinton qui était soi disant
gravement malade en 2016 pendant la
campagne bien sûr disent qu'elle a perdu
isabelle adjani qui avait le sida
les rumeurs c'est pas à prendre à la
légère chez les stars parce que ça peut
les faire ou les desserts chipé rebond